la sécheresse chez nous au pire elle se
traduit par un appel aux vacanciers les
priant de limiter leur douche
quotidienne
ici au coeur de l'afrique la sécheresse
c'est la mort
mort du bétail au niger par exemple 80 %
du cheptel a disparu
la mort des cultures plusieurs années
consécutives de sécheresse ont fait
considérablement baisser la nappe d'eau
souterraine
on parie les pluies et à sécher les
cours d'eau
mort d homme est d'abord les petits des
hommes de l'atlantique à l'océan indien
deux millions et demi de personnes
rayées de la carte
actuellement le manque d'eau condamne
près de 5000 personnes par jour à périr
et ce il faut bien le dire dans
l'indifférence de l'opinion publique
pour les nomades et semi nomades des
pays du sahel le seul espoir est au bout
de plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
marche dans le désert jusqu'aux camps de
secours
là on leur fournit un minimum
alimentaire on leur assure des soins
médicaux
la variole la rougeole et le choléra
s'acharne en effet sur les populations
moribonde de ces camps bien que très
insuffisante une aide internationale
existe mais encore faut-il assurer le
transport des denrées
les seuls camions tous terrains
disponibles sur place appartient à
l'armée française les a mis à la
disposition des autorités locales
mais souvent cela ne suffit pas
ils ont perdu la totalité de tout leur
bétail
il ne leur est rien et je pense pas que
ça sert à normaliser d'ici quelques
années
quelques années à condition que vienne
la pluie à condition qu en attendant la
reconstitution problématique des
troupeaux soit assurer l'alimentation ou
plusieurs millions de personnes seuls
les pays du sahel n'en n'ont pas les
moyens à condition que des capitaux soit
consacrée à la mise en oeuvre de projets
à long terme d'irrigation par exemple à
condition que à condition que à
condition que surtout dans les pays
riches
chez nous la prise de conscience la
bonne volonté la générosité sauve les
populations du sahel de leurs effrayants
agonie